das heißt wenn ihr euch diesen glatten
sandstein einfach nimmt da ist eine
geheimnisvolle botschaft wohl irgendwie
drauf und herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge minecraft heute am
freitag wie eventuell in der folge am
dienstag schon mitbekommen habe bin ich
immer noch ein paar produzieren
allerdings habe ich heute wieder richtig
richtig cooles für euch am start
und es kommt sogar heute eine kleine
sache die niemandem in minecraft
aufgefallen ist was sehr sehr mysteriös
haben da eventuell die illumination aber
ich würde sagen bevor wir lange rum
reden ich hab schon gesehen effekt
nummer eins obwohl wurde zugesendet von
larissa und zwar mein sakko crafter ja
wie einen coolen faken nummer eins man
kann hunde mit verorteten fleisch für
den oder bekommt keinen schaden ich habe
hier schon einen hund der ist jetzt mal
und weil ich da mit knochenresten
rumlaufen mit einer leine blabla ich
zitiere mal so ein bisschen hoch und
wieder runter damit ein bisschen schaden
bekommt jetzt bot sich den irgendwie
noch zwei mal so und jetzt seht ihr ja
man kann ja am schwanz erkennen man kann
einem schon zu erkennen wie viel leben
er hat also seht schon der schwarzen
relativ weit unten
jetzt kann ich allerdings auch
verrottetes falschen und jetzt achtet
man auf den schwanz
er geht nämlich damit auch hoch das
heißt er geht damit genauso hoch wie
irgendwie mit ganz normalen gebratenem
fleisch als wenn ihr verrottetes fleisch
nicht essen sondern einfach für euren
hund aufbewahren und cooper der der nix
ja schon sollte seite gibt mir blabla
auch wenn das verrottet ist nimmt der
und mich das fleisch das hilft ihm
trotzdem das perfekt nummer eins und
danke an die klare nummer zwei wurde mir
zugesandt von der da oben xd cooler name
jedenfalls meint der mann kann ab
version 1.8 knöpfe auf dem boden
platzieren viele leute schreiben immer
joker du musst deine minecraft folgen
changelog nennen weil du immer sachen
vor stefan hinzugefügt wurden allerdings
sind das denke ich dinge die ich die
sache jetzt nicht beispielsweise hat der
1.8 kann man jetzt übrigens hat man
dieses holz hier neu und diese stufen
und blabla sondern es ist einfach eine
ganz coole sache zu wissen dass man
knüpfe jetzt auf dem boden platziert und
ich wette dass es noch nicht alle von
euch wussten dass das ganze funktioniert
weiß ich mich jeder die ganzen change ob
durchlesen durchliest und so dass auf
jeden fall richtig richtig richtig coole
sache vor allem für adventure maps
hersteller dass man einfach knöpfe auf
bodenplatten kann doch nicht immer dazu
gezwungen ist die im bonner seite zu
machen von einer tür oder keine ahnung
ich finds auf dem boden sieht doch
irgendwie viel cooler als irgendwie
einer wand oder so mit dem holz und so
ich finde auf jeden fall richtig cool
ich wusste es nicht weil ich mir den
kompletten changelog nicht durchgelesen
habe aber das war auf jeden fall fekter
2 zugesendet von der da oben und jetzt
komplex nummer drei dieser effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von fabio algari topos 4
und zweimal der seite 198 fliesst
gezündet das tnt mit dem wasser mit ich
habe hier schon so eine kleine
wasserrutsche gebaut ihr seht schon die
fließt ihr einfach unter uns fließt
unten so einflussreich ist sehr sehr
naturell wie so eine quelle
ich setze jetzt hier einfach mal so ein
tier 1 zündet das ganze jetzt an der 107
und davor ist dann einfach hier
stehengeblieben
hier kann ich das allerdings mal
anzünden und es fließt jetzt einfach ihr
dieses ding runter und explodiert dann
da unten das ist auf jeden fall richtig
richtig cool ich weiß nicht ob hier oben
auf funktioniert müsst ihr eigentlich
war das wasser sich dann der theoretisch
herumschleudern
hier funktioniert auch finde ich auf
jeden fall richtig richtig cool dass das
wasser jetzt dass das wasser mit dem tnt
film mit kies dass das team mit dem
wasser mit vlies genauso wie wenn ich
jetzt an ranschmeißen würde fände ich
auf jeden fall richtig cool und bz wenig
cool finde ich cool wald so ist und du
kleine schiffchen du bringt ihr denkt
ich habe ein ganz normales die
protection pack drin denkt identität in
norwegen nämlich 3d welten guckt mal
wenn hier nämlich jetzt beispielsweise
diese items in setzte das sind jetzt nur
ein ganz partyleben rausgenommen habe
ich jetzt einfach genau wahrscheinlich
genau neben tageslicht sensors vollidiot
sitzen mal kurz wieder neuen etwas
anderen reihenfolge sehr klug dass das
handy direkt neben dem tageslicht werden
bei tageslicht gesetzt habe
jedenfalls wollte ich nur sagen dass
dieser effekt mir zu gesendet wurde von
lars und zwar ist ein 3d etwas ganz
anderes experiment nämlich dass es seit
der 18 diese möglichkeiten gibt nicht
nur die texturen zu ändern sondern auch
das an also nicht nur das aussehen von
einem blog sondern auch die textur so
ein bisschen und diese trivia so ein
bisschen also seht schon hier das ist in
3d alles und wir haben hier dieses
crafting fällt in 3d da haben wir diesen
diesen button in den ofen kann man
wirklich rein gucken dass tnt hat die
wirklich sondern solle zündung aufkleber
schon drum rum hier das ganze hat ein
loch der tages sich zt 3d diese teile
sind einfach total massiv geworden
richtig richtig cool wir haben hier auf
jeden fall richtig richtig cool effect
finde ich das ist nämlich in der 1.8
möglich ist diese ganzen text für uns
ein bisschen 3d mäßig zu gestalten danke
an dich lass er hat mir das sexy back
auch zugesendet ich möchte ich selbst
allerdings nicht in die beschreibung
packen weil ich nicht weiß ob er nicht
will dass sich das ganze veröffentliche
und blabla deswegen lars wenn du dich
hier irgendwie anschauen solltest guckt
doch einfach mal die kommentare bisschen
ganze scheibe war mir die kommentare und
postet dadurch eventuell mal den
downloadlink fallen das wäre auf jeden
fall richtig cool aber ich denke auch
sonst dass es schon andere texture pack
supporten wahrscheinlich oder ich weiß
es nicht genau jedenfalls war das bag
nummer vier jetzt kompakt 05 der fünft
effekt wurde mir nämlich zugesendet von
minecraft trikot und zwar meint der
schau doch einfach mal im great if not
und baumaterial und nimmt mir immer so
einen glatten sonnenstein ich denke so
wahrscheinlich nehme ich mir einfach mal
setzte dahin
was ist denn da ist da ist einfach eine
2 eingraviert es heißt wenn ihr euch
diesen glatten sandstein einfach nehmen
da ist eine geheimnisvolle botschaft
wohl irgendwie drauf ich weiß nicht ob
er sich in das ganze reinsteigern ich
mich auch wahrscheinlich schon
und es ist auch mehr oder weniger so ein
kleiner fun fact den hatten wir auch
schon lange nicht mehr diese fun fact an
alle die ganz lange schon mit ihrer
serie der weisen kann eventuell ii fun
facts noch wo es damals nur drei
normalem ein präfekt waren und ein fun
fact ist ein bisschen chaotisch ist und
zwar ist hier einfach seine zwei
eingraviert ich weiß nicht was da steht
ich habe dazu keine info gefunden im
forum oder irgendwie sowas wenn ich es
musste ein gegeben habe wenn ihr wisst
warum der eventuell zwei steht dann
schreibt sie doch einfach mal die
kommentare und ich würde sagen wenn wir
freitag schon die das keine tolle
geräusch haben
denkt euch doch einfach mal aus wofür
diese zwei auf diesen glatten sandstein
stehen könnte eventuell
ganz coole kreative sachen wären die
eventuell aber ganz witzig zu lesen für
mich fertig und ich würde sagen das
war's dann auch schon mit den heutigen
minecraft wenn es euch gefallen hat
bitte zeigt dass mit einer bewertung
weil dieser serie immer so ein bisschen
kritik steht von wegen ich kannte diese
anschauen und als möglicher zeit
unterstützt mich mit einem daumen hoch
wenn ich diese serie gefallen und je
mehr folgen davon haben wollte und dann
würde ich sagen
sein kontrakt ihm an dort kommunen und
in der nächsten folge wie petz